when my kids walk into a bodega in
Newark they can get a twinkie-like
product cheaper than an apple because we
as a society have said we're going to
subsidize everything in that
twinkie-like product and not the Apple
I've had the great privilege of speaking
with many people who are making a real
difference in the world and today's
guest certainly fits that description
Democratic senator Cory Booker of New
Jersey senator Corey Booker
a headline grabbing former mayor who
says he's the only vegan in Senate
history Corey is a graduate of Stanford
University where he played varsity
football
[Music]
Rory is the former mayor of Newark New
Jersey he was a 2020 presidential
candidate and is currently a leading
voice in the United States Senate
congratulations senator
in this conversation we discussed
Corey's path to Public Service talk
about the divided nature of politics
today and we also talk about a topic
that is near and dear to both of our
hearts food policy reform Ultra
processed foods now compose two-thirds
of the calories in the diets of our
children and teens
the underlying theme of this
conversation however is really about how
we can all embrace the power we all
possess to catalyze substantive change
and then shouldering that responsibility
to drive change within ourselves within
our communities and even on a national
level the power that you always have
over and over again is to choose how you
are going to respond are you going to
double down on the darkness or the
negative frequencies or are you going to
be like the heroes we Elevate in this
country that will choose faithfulness or
hopefulness or ultimately the highest
frequency of all love it was a true
honor to spend a couple hours with
Senator Booker I have been inspired by
his example as a public servant for many
many years he is a man who truly walks
his talk I was quite moved by what he
shares in this exchange and uh I hope
you find it as meaningful as I did
before we get into it this video is
brought to you today by Roca I can ask
constantly about the glasses that I wear
on the show they are Roca I love them
super light perfect for your active
lifestyle tons of great Styles amazing
Optics they never slip off your face and
you're going to hear much more about
Roka a little later on so here we go
this is knee and Senator Cory Booker
um I can't tell you how excited I am to
have you here today we made it happen
I've been wanting to meet you for so
long so I'm just thrilled that you're
here today yeah I I told my staff I was
going to try not to make a fool out of
myself and Fanboy all over you uh I've
dreamed of having a conversation with
you uh a lot and uh Spotify is which I
listened to you they give me my most
listened to songs every year and you
know
Bruce Springsteen Stevie Wonder kind of
thing but the podcast now they've been
saying so last year you were my number
one most listened to podcast and I don't
know what to tell you I I uh but you
know there's a saying you probably know
it's about friendship and it says uh a
true friend is somebody that knows the
song of your heart and we'll sing it to
you when you've lost the tune and what
we don't know each other personally but
I cannot tell you how many nights and
myself knows this I sometimes will wake
up at four o'clock in the morning can't
fall back asleep and I'll go to you and
it's like having a friend uh resonate
the values that are important to you I
just find this uh for a long time found
this kinship with you that I don't even
know you but you have really helped me
in my own life journey and my life path
so it's incredibly meaningful to me to
hear that it's it's like emotional to
hear that uh because you know if we just
do this thing and uh you know it's very
abstract like I do it and then I go home
and I see numbers and I know people are
listening to it and watching it but
um to get that kind of feedback is like
you know that's my nourishment so I
appreciate that and and you know on the
subject of values like I am I am uh you
know just
somebody who has so much respect for uh
you know how you kind of comport
yourself in the world not just as a
senator as a representative of your
constituents but as a human being as a
man how you kind of model healthy
masculinity healthy masculinity how you
model leadership and how you really
um walk your talk in terms of the things
that are important to you and the
positions that you take often difficult
positions in terms of your activism and
the kind of positive change that you're
trying to actualize in the world I mean
we're all journeying right and
um so I you know it's it's I always say
we're all mountain ranges we all have
Peaks we all have valleys and a lot of
your work is trying to get your Peaks to
go higher and get your valleys to become
level and what I admire about you is
you're a guy who has been so
courageously vulnerable and I think that
in that vulnerability you've showed the
best of who you are and I was I was
telling my team and on the way here and
again I feel like I again this is our
first time meeting but I feel like I
know you so so well I'm surprised we
because we overlapped it I think we did
well I graduated in 89. yeah so you were
91 right so we were there two years at
the same time yeah and to the extent
that we were in the training room at the
same time you as a swimmer uh me as a
football player we may have we may have
maybe bumped into each other well we
shared the weight room yes at different
times yes you know um but you have been
so open about your own journey of of uh
mistakes Brokenness struggling with
addiction and I in many ways I think
that the the people I come to admire the
most are those who have lost pretense
and uh affectation and are are learning
to be comfortable in the truth that
they've lived which is often we all
carry with us trauma shame pain and
um I think the more at peace we are with
that as a part of our growth uh the more
we're able to touch other people in
their authentic space and you do that so
eloquently and
um persistently that is a gift to
everybody who I think who listens yeah I
appreciate that I mean I've discovered
that it that's how you breed trust and
and community and it's an antidote to
loneliness you know because everybody is
going through something and I don't care
how they characterize their life on
Instagram or how great something might
look on the outside or the the the ways
in which we project or judge a person
based upon how they present to us you
know nobody gets out of life alive and
we all have our private struggles and
you know part of part of kind of uh you
know what I what I try to do is to try
to tap into you know the core of
humanity that we all share so we can
find that commonality and I think that
that's something that you would you know
agree is an important thing particularly
in you know how you how you you navigate
descent and how you speak about
the division that we're experiencing and
right in in America right now and you're
kind of recipe for repairing that uh in
terms of like Building Bridges rather
than you know kind of uh you know
dropping explosions here and there yeah
and it's hard it's harder and harder in
in uh in today's context where we have
as a tower box as a sort of severed
belonging that you know where a species
that's involved over a millennium in
these really tight-knit nurturing
communities where you're known where
you're seeing
um where you're connected and we have a
society now which we're not not as
connected I think there's some data
recently came out about men and how we
have less friends than we've ever had at
least from an American context
and that really is
um there's an there is a unspoken
perhaps unfully realized Agony and all
of that that I think feeds a lot of
dysfunction in our not just with
individuals when you feel isolated and
alone and lacking connection
um but I think if you're in the larger
society as well as well and this is
being aggravated by our larger political
context which is so much right now
affected by concentrated corporate
culture that has their own urgencies
which is you know we're far more
shareholder profit driven than we've
ever been there was a time when my dad
was coming up in fact that corporations
had multiple shareholders not just the
people that actually own it but the
community in which they're in and the
employees
and so what that is driven is this
unbelievable urgency to keep people's
eyes on screens
and I just really worry about us and how
we're going to get out of this trap that
the way people often think about getting
eyes in this on the screens is driving
us further apart from each other or or
accessing our
um our our sense of outrage or or this
culture of contempt
um and so in politics I'm on my team is
often talking about how do we scratch
that record how do we get out of this
trap where we're viewing Americans
fellow Americans as enemies or threats
to the point where we consider them
existential threat if you win it can and
mean the end of this nation if both
sides have that kind of rhetoric
um and and it's creating this
environment where I can say
metaphorically it's like this nation has
this ship that is one of the best ships
in the entire fleet of other countries
ships and we're way out ahead we've been
doing things that have been the Marvel
of humanity for a long time uh whether
that we used to be from 1940s to the 19
early 19th he's the biggest expansion of
middle class
um uh people we had a doubling of median
income the black white wealth Gap was
shrinking we've done things in humanity
from mapping the human genome
to Defying Gravity and getting to the
moon but now our ship is in danger and I
see this in a in many ways in Washington
DC when we look at measures of
competitiveness but that's not the best
measure but we're in danger because
we're fighting each other so much that
our ship is stalling we're threatening
uh to put holes in the ship and be
overtaken
um and so how do we heal that how do we
get out of that trap and we think a lot
about that and one is just trying to be
that change and I have definitely made
mistakes in my political career
um where I have fallen in the Trap of
demonization and there are times when
I've been able to find creative ways out
of that
um I often say two of my best teachers
in life are have been Donald Trump and a
guy named sharp James were my two you
know sharp dreams was my sort of Nemesis
there was a documentary made about my
campaign to try to become mayor of the
city in Newark called street fight and
he brought the best of me and at times
the worst of me and there are uh it was
with Donald Trump I say the same thing
he's brought out some of the uglier
Corners that I had to work on as well as
some of the better things and so
I you embody this so much it's the self
work that ultimately makes us
the best external leaders when it comes
to making change and making a difference
and so I appreciate the compliment but
I'm still working on this how do we how
do we solve this trap by solving it for
myself sure I mean those types of
extreme personalities can be a mirror uh
reflecting back what you need to work on
within yourself because that's the only
thing that you can truly control but in
thinking about the landscape clearly uh
you know we all live in this attention
economy and what traffics is outrage and
you know politics is certainly at the
you know core of this ecosystem in which
pushing buttons and you know saying uh
you know sort of being oppositional
rather than solution oriented is what
you know kind of creates traction on the
internet and gets people enervated and
energized and all of that
um and and to kind of stand as a
Counterpoint to that and say I'm not
going to be complete sit in that economy
and I'm going to you know sort of stand
on my own two feet and and and speak up
for the values that you know I espouse
and instead of casting aspersions talk
about Solutions is something that gets
kind of denigrated in the algorithm
doesn't get the Mind share that it
should so it's the harder Road right and
I would imagine in in Washington that
can be frustrating
I mean that's an understatement but uh
you know and I get I have many chapters
of that frustration where I'm feeling
I'm banging my head against these
implacable walls that divide us as a
society when when I go out in the public
in America I just find a lot more
Community or connection if you can break
through
the politics of it all I I
um
and I know we'll get to talk about this
but I have shifted to the AG committee
which is something I never thought I
would do the agricultural committee uh
um I I just when I got to Washington I
just never imagined I would be looking
at Food Systems yeah
um but as a precursor to that I I wanted
to travel out and meet rural Farmers
because I really do believe there is a
spiritual and a and a material truth to
King's ideal that he wrote about in the
letters from the Birmingham Jail that
were all caught in an inescapable
network of mutuality tied in a common
Garment of destiny that Injustice
anywhere is indeed a threat to Justice
everywhere and so rural towns in America
are really really suffering
um and the farming and agriculture as we
know it if we went back four generations
what's going on now our ancestors might
even consider it a perversion of uh the
ideals that really helped to to build
this country and so we went out to just
meet with Farmers a lot of Republican
farmers and I remember going to this one
Farm where the guy my the my Sherpa the
guy bringing me around told me later the
guy didn't even want me in this house he
called him up and said we're a Christian
family we can't have Cory Booker in our
house which is which is like I you know
I'm a Christian that not that that had
something to do with it but
um so I get out of my car and I kind of
feel this like tension towards me with
the guy and he takes me down to his you
know Farm area shows me his cows and
everything and I'm horribly corny uh
myself allows me one dad joke a day so
here goes uh I would say things to him
like sir your cows are utterly amazing
you know I milked every joke I could uh
but he didn't crack and we eventually
get into his table and it's his
neighbors there and we start talking
about their experience
when I noticed when we got in that he
had the deed to his the family deed to
the land that I think he must have
gotten way back in the homestead act
because it's uh um you know like a
century old and everybody it worked for
farming worked for every generation but
he was now in danger of losing the farm
because the economics have changed so
dramatically you know you have instead
of many companies selling you inputs you
had one major dominating company in
Monsanto now bear instead of having five
companies bidding for his cattle uh he
had won in fact one company dictating
price the his neighbor was afraid to
talk openly about it because he was
afraid of being cut off
and when they start explaining their
fears and their worries and what this
system did it it opened me up and we
started talking more and when they
realized I agreed with them and that I
was going to be pushing legislation to
stop this corporate consolidation and
create more fair farm systems this
that's when the tension broke and we
realized we had shared values by the end
they were calling he's calling out his
family were taking selfies
but so that's I find that we we have far
more in common than we don't but trying
to break through to that is a is a hard
thing and and these outrage machines
and I don't mean that I'm not just
pitching
factually and it's not just social media
uh one of my friends is a guy named Van
Jones who
um uh had a show called Crossfire
and um went on that show with Newt
Gingrich and I think brene Brown's right
it's hard to hit up close so pull people
in and lo and behold the two of them
working together they realize they liked
each other and and they agreed on things
like they may had a lot of things they
disagreed with but they found that they
had substantive areas of overlap and
they wanted to talk about it so they did
the last segment called ceasefire and
they got the producers who really let
them do it but it got ended quickly
because ratings were going down right
and and so these corporations who want
to keep our eyes on the screen the
easiest to sell not not always the best
but the easiest sell and people like
Oprah and others have have found ways to
tap into the human yearning for
inspiration for Hope for love but the
easier sell off then is fear and hate
and Division and moral outrage and so
that's the system that's being
supercharged by the devices we have
fractured media where we all you and I
grew up around the same errors we all
watched the final episode of mash we all
watched Roots there's these cultural
anchors but now they're are far more
fractured and we can navigate into these
worlds in which we are all listening to
the same perspective we're all having
our ideas confirmed and we're all
creating common enemies which is the
authorization and it's a it's a unique
human story this contest in humanity
between those who want to expand the
conceptions of US versus them and those
who want to expand the consumptions of
Just Us justice and and it's and and
that's the tension that we're in as a
not just as a nation but as a planet
frankly as well it's a bit of a David
and Goliath sort of situation too
because the people who are who are like
yourself who are Waging War against this
notion of otherness and outrage are
doing battle against algorithms and the
siloization and fractured media that is
putting people in those positions to
kind of you know be immune to the kind
of message that you're putting out and
it's it's disheartening and and
fascinating from a forensic sort of
point of view because I'm so I grew up
in Washington and I grew up you know I
went to high school there in the in the
mid-1980s and sort of an inside the
Beltway family and that was a period of
time in which
you know Democrats and Republicans May
disagree on things but there was a
certain level of Comedy like comedy you
know
m-i-t-y like people got along like it
wasn't like a you know it wasn't like I
can't talk to you kind of situation and
you know it seems like that's no longer
the case although I don't live in
Washington anymore
um which
is concerning from the perspective of
trying to
um create change because change requires
consensus and it requires a meeting of
the minds and it requires the ability to
kind of show up and and you know set
your judgments aside and try to just you
know roll up your sleeves and and get
the work done right so first of all it's
not as bad as we perceive there's a lot
of things that get done outside of the
glare of
um of what the news wants to cover that
is but but anybody who's been in
Washington now versus and been there 25
years ago will say we'll confirm
everything you said it used to be far
better but again
we are we I always say uh that human
history is in American history is in
particular like a constant testimony to
the overcoming of seemingly dark uh uh
difficult situations that seem
implacable or seem impossible to
overcome and and it I always try to
return it to me as an individual visual
I could curse the darkness but but am I
really living up to my ideals to try to
change a situation and and one drop in a
pool
can change the the pH balance or the
chemical substance we are far more
powerful agents of frequency change than
we know and so you know my team and I
like I went to Washington and I said
okay Bill Bradley one of my great
mentors uh the senator uh from New
Jersey years before me
um said to me try to meet with every one
of your Republican colleagues just to to
have dinner with them to get them know
them as human beings and so I set out in
this really fun kind of
Odyssey I always say going out to dinner
with Ted Cruz was hard not because not
because uh uh he's a republican I'm a
Democrat but because I'm a vegan and
he's from Texas you know
um but we did go out to dinner and it
was so shocking people like literally
stumbled by us when we were walking and
every once in a while you would see
people uh taking I call them selfies
like taking pictures of the two of us
just because they couldn't believe the
two of us were having dinner but it was
it's something that resulted in showing
me that it is worth the effort Ted Cruz
and I have passed legislation together
but one of my favorite moments was when
I couldn't really get to a guy named
inhof he's just retired but a a
republican right-wing guy who has said
things on the senate floor that I have
found offensive and again I've probably
done things that he finds offensive
again I'm a vegan and he's a guy from a
a traditional family that I'm sure he
sees that in some kind of way but I go
to I go to a Bible study in his office I
hear he has in his Hideaway which of
these cool offices uh closer to the
senate floor this more senior the center
the nicer The Hideaway and so I go into
this really nice office to join him for
Bible study as a way of trying to make a
connection and as soon as I walk in I
have my implicit bias challenge we all
have implicit biases and my implicit
bias was I never expected to see this
right-wing Republican with a picture on
his mantle uh Center placed of him and a
little black girl in an affectionate
Embrace and I call my more senior
Senators older Senators would not buy
their first names by their title so I'm
like Mr chairman who that and he looks
at me he goes well that's my family
member his family adopted this girl out
of a very difficult circumstance he told
me the story I found it really wonderful
and beautiful and then went on with
Bible study well months and months later
there's a big education Bill going
through the United States Senate that
Lamar Alexander the senator from
Tennessee who's also since retired was
guarding the bill not letting any
amendments on the bill
and I was frustrated because I had this
amendment that I really believed in that
would have uh helped homeless and foster
kids and I see uh inhof in the well of
the Senate and I remember this story
that I wouldn't have known about if I
didn't sit down with him and I summoned
that Spirit of that little girl and
walked to talk to him and made my pitch
about it and he knew the circumstance
that this was going to be a clean bill
no amendments but he goes let me think
about this I walk back to my side of the
aisle sit down in my back bench seat and
I suddenly see this guy charging into
the Democratic section it comes up to me
and grunts at me I'm in and starts to
walk away and I'm like what do you mean
and he goes Coryell co-sponsor your your
Amendment and next thing you know I we
get grassly on board and other big
chairman and another person then we go
to to to to to to the manager of the
bill and say you know Lamar chairman
Alexander we have all these Republicans
on and he left the amendment on and it's
now the law of the land and so
there there is this is not a fruitless
Pursuit
um I we can never surrender cynicism no
matter how much the obstacles no matter
how difficult the forces of corporate
consolidation or social media or
politics infected with money
we we still have the ability to not only
make change but enough evidence from
history that is worth the fight and the
challenges is we externalize the problem
so much and we don't see that every
problem we want to criticize that we we
may not be to blame for it but we have
the power and can take the
responsibility for doing something about
it and I always try to reduce the
interactions we have all day like so I
was traveling last year
and I get interactions in the airports
that are often very affirming but
sometimes I always tell people please
send me Mother's Day cards because I get
called mother all the time really oh my
God we live in a very uh restaurant
Senators have doubled and I've had times
where I thought I was going to throw
down I was being yelled at people coming
at me it's a it's a much more tense
environment
um uh especially since over the last
four years or so but um usually they're
very people are extraordinary kind in
airports and often will come up and say
Slimmer to you because I use my social
media platforms not to talk about
politics hallways but to talk about
human virtue and and so I'm putting up
my myself in the overhead finding my
seat people have been really nice to me
and I sit down and a woman
um that was sitting next to her daughter
60 and 80 years old and they were from
Alabama and they look at me and they go
who are you are you a professional
athlete which I find very flattering
um and I go no ma'am I'm a United States
Senator and then they want want to know
what most Americans want to know when
they hear about politics is what tribe
are you in and so they asked me are you
a Democrat or Republican and I go ma'am
I'm a Democrat and she goes well I
should have brought my trump hat and she
looks very sour and angry at me and
that's the moment we all have those
moments we have them around our family
kitchen table sometimes for for
Thanksgiving we have them in our
workplace well you have to decide are
you going to play to that dance of that
tune or try to change the record and I
look at her and I'd surprise her I go
ma'am Donald Trump I go oh my gosh he
signed two of the biggest bills I've
written as a senator one that liberated
thousands of people from prison called
the first step act and I described the
other one they got investment in
low-income areas and she was sort of
shaken by that that's how I came and
before you knew it we were talking about
how the media is separating us far more
than we are and by the end of this long
flight we're having fun we know about
each other in a much more personal way
we're affirming each other's dignity
will she ever vote for me probably never
but will she I maybe have a crack of
humanity or maybe a a like with inhofe
maybe a threat has been taken created
that can be woven into to a cloth that
can be make us more whole as a people
that's what we have that's the challenge
we all have every day but what often
happens instead is we fall into the Trap
of just compounding the frequency and
the energy that we are when I was
running for president in Iowa I was in a
town hall and I'm running for a stage
and I'm about to jump up on the stage
and I see this big dude I played tight
end for Stanford this guy could play
linebacker for Iowa State and he goes
dude I want you to punch Donald Trump in
the face and I look at him and I laugh I
go dude that's a felony and I jump on
the stage and I use him as an
opportunity to talk to this larger crowd
about love and I say you know I sort of
make a joke about our interaction and I
say this is how we lose this is not how
we create change this is how we double
down on divisiveness Division and the
culture of contempt and if you think
about us as a people as the best I don't
think Martin Luther King James bevel
Shuttlesworth all of those people in in
the early 1960s 1963 spring I don't
think any of those people change bull
Connor's mind
but they didn't hate him they didn't
beat him by bringing bigger dogs and
bigger fire hoses what they found a way
to do it was to change the frequency of
this country through their Artistry of
activism they expanded the moral
imagination of a Nation they changed the
consciousness of a country and did what
the real challenge is
King spoke of it more eloquently than I
could he said the problem today what we
have to repent for is not just the
vitriolic words and violent actions of
the bad people but the appalling silence
and inaction of the good people
so if you and I are good people what are
we silent about
where are we not living before I talk
about how bad a republican is or Trump
is where am I participating in systems
that perpetuate Injustice where am I
falling short of my own values if you
work there you will be surprised at how
much that work
um creates more change than if you spend
all your time condemning oh uh pick your
person these days on my side of the L
DeSantis or Trump or or what people
might want to say about Biden or others
we're brought to you today by Roca
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuild
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
it's so clear that cynicism as a default
is ultimately the lazy easy choice but
incentives kind of drive us towards that
right let's be ironic let's be defeatist
let's cast stones at the other side and
talk about how bad they are without
really doing a proper inventory of where
we're at and where we could do better
and a lot of it you know in thinking
about kind of your work and your story
and and where you come from like this is
something you've been practicing for a
long time like an early kind of inciting
incident or inflection point for you was
that
um hunger strike back in New Jersey in
your early days as a city councilman
where you had to confront the mayor who
was your kind of antagonist at the time
and ultimately you know find a way to
you know build consensus with this
person who you struggled with and and
and and and succeeding at that
seems to me to be something that kind of
taught you like this is possible like in
the face of intractable problems you
know hope is always the answer and
doubling Down on Love and and not
letting you know Despair and judgment
and cynicism rule your decision making
and how you kind of you know proceed
forward look this was this was a turning
point in my life to be uh Frank it was
at one of the lowest points of my life
and I think that
this idea that despair is bad look
despair is a necess great despair is a
necessary precondition to manifesting
great hope you know you know this sort
of fear is a necessary precondition to
courage and and and so on
I went from 1997 graduating from Law
School
to uh following the calling of my mom of
all people I was at the age where I sort
of thought my mom had nothing more
original to say but she asked me what
would you do if you knew you couldn't
fail like I didn't I told her I didn't
know what I want to do after law school
she goes what would you do if you knew
you couldn't fail and I never forget
like being haunted by the question like
oh my God if I knew I was going to be
successful what would I do with my life
and uh I started researching who are the
people that most inspire me on the
planet Earth and and maybe I can if I
knew I couldn't fail maybe I'd try to be
my own version of them and I found a
young guy then who's now far more known
but back in the late 90s uh he was sort
of just doing Noble work his name was
Brian Stevenson sure um uh incredible
yeah incredible human being another one
was marrying right Edelman was on my
list another guy named Jeffrey Canada I
don't know if you know him he started
something called the Harlem children's
Zone wrote a book called fist stick
knife gun a little thin book that's
really amazing but his I went out and
met with him followed him around and I
finally concluded if I couldn't fail I
would start this organization in New
Jersey and I came from a you know very
affluent suburb relative to where I
would move from parents who knew a very
different life than I did my father's
born the poor in this he would tell me
don't tell people I was poor just tell
him I was po P.O because I couldn't
afford the other two letters
um and just imagine that culture shock
of now he's raising his kids in this
incredibly affluent area as the first
black family that moved into the town
where they literally had to get a white
couple that poses them to buy the house
in 69. and my dad sort of my mom sort of
challenging us what are you going to do
to prove worthy of this privilege so my
mom challenges me what are you going to
do if you couldn't fail to address your
calling to make the world a better place
because I had that vague desire
so I moved to Newark like Jeffrey Canada
did I find an area that people told me
not to move into low-income neighborhood
I live there now where people don't
mistake wealth with worth and there's a
great definition of faith I love that
when you come to the end of all the
light you know and you're about to step
into the darkness you have the courage
to take that step that faith is known
one of two things is going to happen
either a fine Solid Ground underneath
you or the universe will send you people
who teach you how to fly
and so here I move into this
neighborhood that I found challenging I
was living across the street from
projects that I would soon move into
next to an abandoned building that was
used for uh people using drugs it was a
virulent drug trade going on
but these incredible people sort of
surrounded me saw that I had this desire
recognized things in me I didn't see
myself and before you knew it I'm now
representing these tenant associations
Newark is its name Brick City because it
used to just be full of brick buildings
that were like debris bring projects and
this was a central Ward where there was
just a lot of low-income housing and a
lot of public housing and these tenant
leaders these incredibly Noble wise
people who had earned the love and
respect of their their buildings adopted
me and we started doing just stuff I'm
so proud of taking on slumlords one of
them ended up getting convicted in
federal court I was proud of my life I
thought I'd done it I'm now doing what I
want to do and then they basically
cornered me once and said City Hall's
corrupt we're going to run a campaign
I'm like I'm happy to help you no you
don't understand you're going to be the
candidate right and here I was less than
a year out of law school
um running for office in a city where
incumbent politicians didn't lose
against a guy 40 years older than me if
I would win this race I would become the
youngest person ever elected and these
incredible people wrapped me in their
legitimacy would walk me up and down
buildings and say you may not know him
but you know me this is the person we're
going to support
my opponent got the same amount of votes
he always got we brought out a whole new
electorate won a race by 24 vote like a
few dozen votes and then it begins the
worst year of my life where I get into
City Hall the mayor's joking when people
were going to drive this kid back to the
suburbs I get outvoted eight to one I
went from feeling like I was making a
difference in the world to just this
intractable world of politics and I
became very angry that politics is not a
way to make change
um the mayor was having fun with me he
would put tickets on my car everywhere I
parked you know I'm like you know I park
with other city council people in front
of the city or my driver's license was
being suspended by the Municipal Court
this was the machine oh my god
um and I'm on my day that I'm I call my
quitting day I was now making plans to
convince the tenant leaders that this
was Folly I should go back to being your
full-time lawyer and on that day I get a
call from this incredible woman named
Elaine Sewell who was the tenant
president of these buildings in the
northern part of the ward I represented
right underneath an underpass called 280
which was a perfect place to deal
narcotics drugs because people could get
off the highway go in like a McDonald's
drive through and I'm not exaggerating
people could line up in their cars buy
whatever drugs they want get back on the
highway into the sort of more affluent
suburbs and the security company thought
they newly hired was going to just like
put a gate up and stop the drug dealers
rip the gate off lit the guard booth on
Fire Security Company quit and now on my
quitting day Miss Elaine School calls me
up and says you need to do something
about this and like what are you talking
about I I can't do anything and she's
like well come on we need help maybe you
can get the police out I'm like I can't
get least to stop ticketing my car for
crying out loud and we started arguing
this woman who walked me through her
buildings in an election I won by a few
dozen votes is now trying to tell me
that she needs help and I'm trying to
tell her how impotent I am we start
raising our voice at each other and then
she says the most hurtful thing in my
life though I think somebody had said to
me at that point she goes if well if you
can't help us why did we elect you in
the first place
and I
slam the phone down disrespecting my
Elder storm back to where I was living
and and all I want to do is get into my
you know apartment in the projects and
just hang out with my two best friends
Ben and Jerry because I want to draw My
Sorrows my addiction food right and
um the the worst thing that I thought
could happen to me is that my tenant
president this woman who is a whole
chapter of my book one of the wisest
Souls I've ever met I'm walking home and
and I grunt to her hello and try to walk
past her and she's just like boy don't
you walk past me and I stop and I turn
around with Fury
because she's the source of my problem
she forced me to run for this office I'm
a politician politicians don't do
anything I was a community activist a
leader
and she goes what's she doesn't she
reads my energy and what she did first
was perfect she just throws at her arms
she goes will you come give Miss Jones a
hug and I was like ah and I storm over
to hercuver the most insincere hug in
the world and and as I let go over she
grabs me by the arm she goes just tell
me what's wrong
and I go you want to know what's wrong
and I vented on her of a year of my life
of getting nothing done outvoted eight
to one this was a mistake that you
forced me into I'm sorry but you were
wrong and then I start complaining about
this terrible violent incident and and
how missoul called me for help and I
don't know what to do and I said it and
you know how this can be when you're in
this loop I said like an incantation
like a mantra I don't know what to do I
don't know what to do professing my
impotence and then this woman looks at
me like God just talked to her she
almost gasps and she's like I know what
I know what you should do and I'm like
excited maybe she does I stopped my pity
party and I go what should I do and then
she looked at me like with this wise
look yep Corey I know what you should do
and I'm like don't play with me Miss
Jones what do I do and she leans in
as if she's about to tell me words from
Angels wisdom from Solomon and she goes
you should do and I'm like yeah yeah
something and I was just like I'm like
yeah something that's it and she goes
yeah do something and I storm away from
her get back to my buildings damn
elevators don't work hike up 16 flights
of stairs sit on my couch angry at the
world feeling sorry for myself having a
life that I did not want and I remember
my grandmother's Bible sitting there and
I opened this thing up and there's a
passage that says if you had if you have
faith the size of a mustard seed you can
move mountains I've seen it a lot but I
never really noticed there's a passenger
that says but sometimes you need to fast
and pray
and then I did the thing that that uh
that Miss Jones inspired and changed my
life which I said
um I got nothing to lose I got nothing
to lose
and so I go out to Garden spiers long
story shorter and I
I brought a tent with me and we
constructed this tent between the two
projects in the drug dealers territory
where the melee had gone on before Miss
Sewell comes out
and sees me and I go over ready to sort
of with shame apologize to her and she
doesn't let me do it she runs to me like
I'm the Prodigal Son hugs me because she
didn't want me to solve her problems she
just want me to show up and care
and there was tears I'm not crying she
was crying I'm lying I was crying
um but um
we talked and I told her what my plan
was and then I did what politicians have
to do you got to learn how to do this I
called a press conference and I said
this is the United States of America how
could people live in fear
where you don't let your kids play in
front of where you live or you don't
feel comfortable going to the corner
store and I talked about the incident
the night before and I just said I've
decided not to leave this tent I'm gonna
stay there and I'm not gonna eat I'm
gonna go on hunger strike and I'm gonna
pray and I want anybody who wants to
pray with me to just pray that we
together can find a solution and the
first night was scary we there's four or
five of us who volunteered to sleep
under the tent together Mrs Sewell
joined us for the first prayer
but I woke up the next morning and the
Miracle started happening the the first
was like these group of guys I don't
remember the eight or so of them come
out to me early in the morning and they
say are you Cory Booker and I said yeah
one of them's like I grew up in this
neighborhood I'm not I'm not letting you
be out here alone we're correctional
officers and they took a position around
the tent
within two or three days hundreds and
hundreds of people were coming offering
help hospitals came out to do Health
screenings one group were fitting kids
with eyeglasses who couldn't see
blackboards but never been diagnosed
computers were donated people built a
computer lab for uh folks to print
resumes or kids to use job fairs you
name it by the by the tenth day of this
hunger strike thousands of people had
come out it was an incredible
celebration of community under and
underpass where people used to ignore
and then the mayor finally came out uh
after being beat up in the newspaper he
comes up to me with his fire department
police department inspectors he brought
everybody was rolling deep and the two
of us meet in this circle of humanity
hundreds of people and I look at him and
I suddenly feel the same impulse that
Miss Sewell had and this is my Nemesis
but I ran to him and I hugged him and
I'll never forget the moment
where I am holding them tight this
newspaper took a picture of that that
became the big picture in the state's
newspaper but the moment that was most
meaningful to me in this Hawk was I
smelled him I breathed deep and and he
smelled like an older black guy from my
family
and he seemed to be so caught off guard
by the hug that he puts away his
prepared remarks and then prophesizes
and we would go on to have a really
really bare-knuckle fight for the
mayorality a couple years later but he
prophesies he goes one day this young
man will be the mayor of this city will
lead this city and there was celebration
like I will never forget uh afterwards
but um
you don't know this but this is the 25th
anniversary of uh this month this day 25
years ago I was a 20 something year old
kid
um knocking on doors with tenant leaders
running for the office that would start
my political career
and this year January I decided to do
see if I could break a 10-day fast so
this this January uh I fasted for 10
days in honor of this improbable journey
I didn't plan on being an elected leader
and every day I would go out and walk
the war that I walked 25 years before to
earn the trust of a community they put
their faith in me had really no reason
to uh but thanks to these leaders that
loved me or believed in me
and on the 10th day I decided to walk
from the southern part of the ward I
represented back to Garden spiers I got
on the pavement there's a park that we
built a little pocket park there that we
built when I was married day care center
and preschool
read it hugged a lot of folks but I
needed to stand in the corner and be
alone
because I wanted to reflect on that
moment where former Stanford football
player used to be able to bench you know
350 360 Squad 600 pounds but the
strongest moment of my life up to that
point was when we had the final prayer
a few hundred people
and when I joined hands with these folks
I felt strength like I never did before
and then this under this overpass
saw America
because before that as a black community
but now this circle is black folks white
folks Latino Asian Indian Believers and
non-believers
Republican Democrat independent I'm sure
priests rabbis imams ministers we were
all holding hands for a final prayer and
the praying is beautiful
Arabic and Hebrew and I've studied
faiths I love God's I love
manifestations of the Divine people how
people understand it there's a Muslim
word
that means the Oneness of humanity that
I love this Hebrew sayings
my my house be a house of prayer for all
nations
but the the the the idea that I had at
that moment that means so much 25 years
later was this word these three words
from a dead language that are the
Hallmark of a country that we now
probably think are hackneyed or what
have you but I get to see these three
words every day when I go to work in the
United States Senate 25 years later and
that's e pluribus unum I think that the
call of humanity
and definitely the call of this country
is to put more indivisible into a one
nation under God and that moment of my
life where we took a place that was such
there was such a Poverty of empathy
where there was so much power where for
us to make change but somehow you have
suburb versus City sometimes you have
highways cutting through neighbor all
these things that separate us that make
us think we're weak or unable to solve
the biggest problems in the world when
you find creative ways to stitch people
together and let them recognize their
Oneness that's when power is Unleashed
and it and it ultimately became the
theme of my time as mayor where I had
ugly comments made by people about the
city of Newark that we were able to then
get to come to the city and be a part of
its of its Resurgence you had the new
workers that never gave up on their
Community combining with everybody from
The Manhattan Institute a right-wing
Think Tank to businesses on profits
innovators small businesses all of us
coming together to show America that we
could take a city that you think is
crime and Corruption and violence but is
ultimately a place where America can can
Thrive and I always tell people the
American dream isn't real everywhere
it's not real anywhere and I think that
was that was that moment from that
pavement to the moment of my last hours
as mayor of the city of Newark it was a
Contin newest theme of the power of
community what a incredibly potent and
Powerful Story I mean it's it's so
beautiful I mean there's so many kind of
threads to pull to you know extrapolate
meaning out of that but for me like it's
it's so moving to hear you tell that
story
um
and the idea that it all tracks back
to your frustration and somebody's
saying do something and you trying to
identify like anything that you could do
that is within your power
without knowing where that would lead
and then to see kind of the ripple
effect of just taking a simple action
and the lesson being that we are all uh
you know we are all people of agency
with more power than we allow ourselves
to believe and when we recognize this
and take responsibility for that and
then Channel it into some kind of Civic
action you know whatever we're capable
of doing or using our voice you know for
for for good we can't anticipate
um the chain reaction that that causes
and and you know to me you stand to
somebody you're an Exemplar of that like
yes you have this huge platform but
you're always talking about how you know
we all have we all have our platforms
and you're always encouraging people to
find ways to use our voices
um to speak up and and you know to kind
of voice the world that we would like to
see you know manifest and to do those
small things because the Small Things
end up becoming the big things yeah but
I don't want to candy coat this I mean
the world is full of wretchedness and
pain and and you and I are both
examples of people that have a lot of
Shame and mistake and hurt
um I when I was running for president I
the last days of my campaign we knew we
were it was coming to a close but I went
to the New York Times editorial board
interview anyway and
um
this is sort of in many ways my backyard
paper or right across the river and it
was the end of the interview and they
said we have speed questions we've been
asking every candidate and and they
thought they were going to do a speed
round but I still remember they they
asked me what's something you really
regret and the first thing I thought of
was again uh I have a lot of things that
if I could go back in life I do
differently I don't regret them in the
sense that I've learned from them but
um there are things that you can't undo
that you've done or mistakes that you've
made that will they'll break you and I
tell people all the time I
where I have Newark broke me like
literally to the point where you have
those kind of gut-wrenching uh uh hurt
and and for me it was this uh it's what
I told the New York Times I said but
look I was
I so I would go on from that was that
was 99 2000 the story I just told you I
would go on and battle the mayor in this
uh uh election in 2002 which I would
lose the the Oscar nominated documentary
about it I was joke because it lost in
the Oscars to march of the bag named
penguins and
um uh but uh then I had four years to
wait until the next time I ran I went
right back to work doing uh uh sort of
non-profit work in Newark but uh during
that period I'm living in the high-rise
projects it's it was just tough years
tough buildings to live in uh but the
community Miss Jones was our tenant
leader it was so what would rally around
me in such profound ways but this
building I lived in had had this even
those heat and hot water were irregular
and all these things but there's so many
good people and one of the groups of
good people I loved were these kids
living in those buildings uh you know
eight years I watched these kids grow up
from grade school into high school and
one night I'd come home and I smell
marijuana now
inner city black kids do not have the
same uh margins to experiment with drugs
that Stanford students do and I mean the
facts are true there's no difference
between blacks and whites for using uh
uh marijuana or you name the drug but uh
black kids are on like four times will
likely be arrested for it and an arrest
you know if I had arrested my parents
have lawyers and all this kind of things
there'd be stationed house adjustments
low-income black kids don't have that
so I knew there was Crisis and so
and I saw some tagging in there that
that concerned me so I was like fellas I
come home every night we joke before I
go upstairs we just have these great
powwows in the in the lobby but I said
let's go out let's do something and
they're like I go what do you guys want
to do let's go to dinner and they said
let's go to the movies and I said
whatever made the mistake of letting
them choose a movie do not go see saw
two or three or four
and it was this amazing thing I we went
out I brought them to the diner brought
other friends together and again like my
mom what would you do if you knew you
couldn't fail I asked some questions
about their dreams aspirations and there
were incredible dreams and to me I
thought very achievable in fact I
remember one of these kids Hassan
Washington who was my dad
the the the similarities between my dad
and this incredibly young man were Eerie
uh they both were born to single moms
both raised by their grandmothers both
born below the poverty line both had
Wicked senses of humor evidences of
Genius charismatic leaders and I
remember his uh to me was I think he
said something like I want to be on a
automotive repair place and every kid
that talked to me I know somebody that
does I'm going to hook you guys up with
mentors and try to help you out
but it was right on the eve of round two
with sharp James I'm running for mayor
and so I don't follow through on these
things with these kids in the back of my
mind I said when I'm after this election
you know six seven months later I could
I'll I was just so busy chasing after my
Brass Ring my dream to to lead this city
and I would come home at night and these
kids were un were the most grace-filled
kid they would joke with me they would
cheer me on they would hold up signs uh
uh um they would tell me they're gonna
vote for me they were too young but
every night they would lift me up I get
elected I win this time
Newark has I won in a summer where there
was there was Rising murder rates the
city was just having a lot of challenges
and I was intent on being everywhere and
so I was working these Around the Clock
if there was a murder on a sidewalk I
would show up to the shooting give
street level sermons about we're going
to be better than this talk about what
we can do together that we would drive
this murder rate down which we did but a
month into my office
time I get elected there's a there's a
there's a shooting on Court Street in
Newark I I run to the shooting I get
there there's a body covered there is a
another one loaded in an ambulance and
it's right in front of a senior citizen
building a lot of people outside and I
do that I I barely acknowledge that the
death on the sidewalk but I minister to
the living and that day goes on you know
early days in the new office I get home
that night to try to steal a few minutes
of sleep pull out my Blackberry cycling
through the reports that I wanted to
look at and there's the crime reports
and I see the homicide and then I see
um
the name on the on on the homicide
report the the the dead body and and it
was Hassan Washington
and and that is something that's broken
to me that will never fix
and and I remember the
just the feeling you stare at something
long enough and you hope and you pray
that you could make it change just by
looking at it
and and everything collapsed on me
and and I remember this gut because my
dad would joke with me as a kid about
his life and how you owe debts that you
can't pay back that you've got to pay
forward
and so here the universe put my father
just as smart as my dad just as
charismatic as my father
everything that my dad was better than
me
in so many ways this young man got the
universe put it in him in front of me my
dad would say that he was saved by his
community but for people that went out
of their way and here he was put on my
foot with steps and I didn't I didn't do
all that I could seeing the signs
and his funeral I describe it in a way
that hearkens back to dark chapters
because for me it was in Perry's Funeral
Home in the basement of that funeral
home
narrow steps going down you feel like
you're descending into the hull of a
ship and there is my community chained
together
wailing and moaning and swaying back and
forth
looking at what is an American
weekly if not daily
event which is another black boy in a
box
and I am choking in this basement
and people are coming over to me now the
father of the city
and I can't I can't help them because
I'm lost in shame I'm lost in hurt
and I'm I'm embarrassed to tell you
I was so suffocating I ran out of there
told my security detail we're leaving
get into my brand new you know City SUV
back to my new office this palatial
mayor's office slam the door shut sit on
the couch and for my first time as mayor
not the last just weep into my hands
and
just pray to God
that I could somehow make up for this
sin
and and so you know I get emotional but
this ain't easy you know and I don't
want to ever like people say oh you know
you're so full of Hope real hope
is scarred
real hope is wounded real hope has had
to be resurrected more than once
real it's not Pollyanna stuff
in America right now there are kids
considering suicide as we're having this
because this world has made them feel
lesser than because of who they are
there are
people hurting with at a kitchen table
so they don't know how the economics are
going to work there is real pain and
hurt and and and the answer isn't to
Buck up and be positive the answer is to
confront it
and somehow
if you're fortunate enough like I am or
you are or we all are at some point to
find a way to connect and let people
know that you're not alone that we're
all broken we all effed up multiple
times but as broken as we are
ultimately
those cracks make it and those Jagged
edges we all have perhaps make it better
to fit together with other people who
are just as broken and fractured uh to
create a stronger whole and a better
bond that gives it gives hope
yeah thank you for sharing that
um
I was listening to your conversation
with Jane Goodall who wrote the book of
you know she wrote a book about Hope
right and and you guys had a Frank
conversation about the nature of Hope
and and and you know the idea that that
real hope is is what you do in the face
of of being truly tested right and and
this idea that hope is the conviction
um that you said something like hope is
the conviction that despair doesn't get
the last word exactly right so it's like
it ain't easy it's [__] hard and you
know the vulnerability with which you
just shared that story and the the pain
you know the kind of uh
spiritual psychic pain that that must
have caused you knowing that it wouldn't
have been that hard for you to extend a
hand and and perhaps help that kid and
maybe divert that situation from
happening is something that you'll take
to your grave right and and but that's
um
and the flip side of this is to is is
this is this delusion that something
doesn't matter you know everything
matters like you may say a kind word to
somebody like I just my brother on
Thursday
uh I thought he had another stroke
and my my brother's my hero he's like
the better Booker by far and
um
and so I'm in the Senate my staff is
calling me trying to desperately get to
me and I I I and I see this like
emergency I'm thinking like okay I
forgot to vote on the floor or something
like that and no they're trying to get
to me because my my sister-in-law is
calling me that my brother had a stroke
and so I find the news and now I'm in
fear like I don't know what I'll do with
my I I should make my brother sign a
contract that I get to die before him uh
so I'm now rushing dropping everything
um Veronica takes me to train she's like
knows how desperate I am to get from
Washington DC to New Jersey the train
gets canceled they my my incredible a
team member calls me up and says I'm
sorry this one flight one seat it's
first class it's gonna cost you you know
X thousands of dollars I'm like put it
on my credit card I need to get to New
Jersey so this moment from my time
getting to the airport to getting to
uh my brother's bedside I'm panicked I'm
scared
I'm imagining all of the worst case
scenarios and trying to fight them back
but nobody knows that as I'm walking
through airports where everybody's
recognizing me and I will never forget
this moment where I we land and it's
it's I have to get out on the tarmac
usually you go through the and I come
down the tarmac and there's a people
mover that's gonna you know drive me
there and I get on the People Mover and
I sit down and people are recognizing me
but I've got all the swirl in my head
and then the men and women that work on
the tarmac
see me inside
and they come in and almost as if some
Divine Angel was saying this they didn't
say hi mayor they come over in a line
like three or four of them to hug me and
every hug I leaned into in a way that I
never had before because God that's what
I needed right then
those people had no idea they thought
whatever they thought they were
holding me together
to get to my brother's uh bedside
and we don't know we pass people every
day and we don't know the power of one
generous Act of decency that's helping
someone hold it together when they're
facing whatever personal crisis they are
and just to not worry everybody he ended
up not having a stroke it would say
seizures
my brother is gonna be okay he is had
some seizures which are as I've learned
are not like a stroke it's no damage see
he's going to recover but
we'd forget the power we have every
single day to be used by the universe in
some way that we will never even
understand the the results of and and
the best story of my life which I think
about all the time is this white guy on
a couch in in March almost to the day
that we're recording this uh in in 1965
March 7th watching TV starting a law
firm busy as hell
watching a movie called Judgment at
Nuremberg they cut away from the movie
and he sees a bridge in Birmingham
uh in in Alabama rather called The
Edmund Pettis bridge and he watches
these people get beaten these
non-violent Marchers led by John Lewis
beaten with Billy club's tear gasps
horses charging in and he's so appalled
by what he's seeing that he says I gotta
go to Alabama then laughs at himself
that he can't he can't afford a plane
ticket not to mention close his business
and so he flops down and then thinks to
himself well I I'm not gonna allow my
inability to do everything to undermine
my determination to do something and so
he's he says to his calculation you can
do one hour a week of pro bono work you
you and I know the legal profession
it doesn't seem like that much one hour
more before going to work and so he
calls around and he finds this woman
named Lee Porter it's young woman now
she's 94 years old back then she was the
head of the Fair Housing Council in New
Jersey Northern New Jersey now at 94
years old she's head of the Fair Housing
Council in New Jersey and they and she's
like he's like do you need some legal
help and she's like hallelujah thank you
Jesus I do they go on this guy to to
form a help to develop these sting
operations where black families go look
at homes
and if they're turned away they send a
white couple volunteering long story
short black family comes in turned away
from home they get back to
uh uh the Fair Housing Council they send
the white couple out it's still for sale
white couple bids on the house the bid
is accepted papers drop on the day of
the closing the white couple doesn't
show up the black man does volunteer
lawyer walk into the house confronted by
the real estate agent they think they've
won the day they didn't because the real
estate agent punches the lawyer in the
face sings a dog on my on the on the
black man and and long story short
eventually the family moves in because
the owners of the home decide to sell it
directly to them and then 43 years later
the youngest kid from that family
becomes America's fourth ever properly
elected black person in the United
States Senate me
got a chance to talk to that lawyer
unfortunately right before he died
and with great emotion thank him
for not just sitting on the couch for
thinking to himself I can do an hour
of pro bono work none of us understand
what our actions are doing in the
immediate context of History
but all of us are part of this lattice
where you can't move without affecting
the strings of that elegant lattice that
could ultimately
move over space and time to affect
outcomes that you're not realizing
nothing is in vain nothing you do is is
useless or unaffecting and and the one
of the quotes I love all the time is the
most common way people give up their
power is not realizing they have it in
the first place and one small act like a
like a pebble in a pond sends out
ripples Beyond a a a your imagination
yeah that's again more profundity I mean
there's a there's a profound
spirituality in that and and there's
something very
um
just empowering about being reminded of
that that truth you know that we all
matter and that again the little things
can be the big things and to not dismiss
ourselves and to really invest in our
own agency yeah and yeah yeah and I I uh
you know I I I just uh uh as I said my
social media we try to post things not
about politics but you wouldn't expect
from a politician so the last yeah
you're that you're you're like you're
the motivational Guru we didn't know we
needed it it's crazy you got you're on
this run streak and then you're you're
like oh there's guys like you that
Timeless wisdom videos every single day
but the guy I the guy I had on uh that I
met at a at an event uh uh Neil deGrasse
Tyson who's this incredible
astrophysicist and I've seen him a few
times I like to tease him because I'm a
you know I again I believe that there's
magic in the universe but I love that
there's this incredible intersection
between science and spirituality that
just excites me you know quantum physics
is fascinating to me and but anyway I
love to tease him because he's I think
in a validation I know you threw a
Zinger at him I did about spirituality I
was like oh I wonder what he's going to
say because I you know I know how he
kind of handles that yes terrain but I
had seen him uh before that and before I
turned on my camera and put him on the
spot
um
it's science right we go at night we
stand up and we we and look at the stars
and I asked him like how far are those
Stars away I said hundreds of billions
of light years and he goes no Corey
millions of light years and I'm like
okay and I said it's true though that
some of those stars that we see is that
are there are actually dead and gone
long time ago but because it takes the
light and energy from those Stars
millions of years to travel to us we see
them as if they're still there
and he's confirms this and I go well
that's very spiritual I am light and
energy and I'll be dead and gone just
like Arthur Lessman is dead and gone
just like uh Frederick Douglass is dead
and gone Ella Baker's dead in uh you
know uh uh Harry but the energy they
gave all they're still stars that still
guide us like North Stars today that's
very spiritual yeah we all will be in we
all are Infinity our bodies may die but
the energy we put out into the world can
never ever stop and and so that's what I
like to think about the ground myself
whether you're a science atheist
scientist
the energy I choose today
into put into this world
is energy that I hope my
great-grandchildren or someone else's
grateful will get a chance to bathe in
and so the one choice I have every day
is my attitude it's my energy you you
know the work of Victor Frankel sure who
I I Used to Know by heart but paraphrase
him he said we were in the concentration
camps remember those people who share
their only piece of bread even though
they themselves were starving who who
comforted others even though they were
suffering the same fate it's a great
test testimony of the greatest of all
human freedoms to choose your attitude
or I would say energy in any given set
of circumstances and so I lean on those
people in my world who uh uh nurture and
Source uh uh even when I'm at my wit's
end or broken that that find a way still
to help me
not let despair have the last word to
choose hope and again I I keep bringing
it back but my
um
you know do work I can never repay my
community for all that they've given me
it's such a special place I just love
places that other people often uh demean
or degrade there is a nobility in my
city of the people that actually live
there and love it and fight for it and
um and and and and and I write about
this a moment in my book you know
we have a real problem in America with
uh um uh just needless violence gun
violence we more people have died in my
lifetime
um you know in my early 50s of gun
violence didn't have died in all the
wars America has been in Combined and
whatever side you are of the of the
debate the reality is we all should have
a moral obligation to stop this level of
Carnage and so again living in an
African-American Community
um where uh there are so many
generational contributing factors to uh
to the problems of violence
um you you tend to see it unfortunately
too much and a lot of the kids that were
with Hassan Washington are dead now
Hassan was not the only person that's
murdered but I'll never forget in that
time between being losing the mayorality
winning the Morality In in just walking
in my neighborhood and a kid was shot
trying to revive him trying to hold them
together
traumatic uh uh the glory for education
we do violence it is ugly it is gruesome
when when somebody has a gun gunshot
wounds and I have no training but I'm
trying to clear what foamy blood from
the kid's mouth holding him together
and it was another point on my journey
where I was ready to be done and where I
felt such anger towards this country
where we swear oh so we say liberty and
justice for all but I couldn't
understand how we could have we have
created such a routine
it's normalized this level of violence
and carnitive scene in no other place on
the planet unless there's it's in a war
we in America or stop paying attention
to this to to gun violence and I
remember that night trying to scrub this
kid's blood off my hands and just
feeling such
vicious anger about this situation
broken again waking up the next morning
and there's this Miss Jones and I'll
never forget when she sees me and holds
me
she just says over and over again to me
as I Cry
stay faithful stay faithful stay
faithful
and they just words right but
it wasn't about religion but here was
this rock a woman whose own son was
murdered in the building in which I
lived
who has seen everything that I've seen
who's hurt this wasn't my child this was
a kid I knew or a kid I encountered
no matter what you're going through and
I guess this is the point I'm trying to
drive home here
the the power that you always have over
and over again
is to choose how you are going to
respond
what are you going to say to this world
are you going to double down on the
darkness or the negative frequencies or
are you going to be like the heroes we
Elevate in this country my greatest
heroes someone that despite the
wretchedness the pain the hurt that will
choose faithfulness or hopefulness or
ultimately the highest frequency of all
love
um
yeah and as I understand it that woman
she stayed in the apartment building
right yes and you asked her like why are
you still here yeah she said something
like well I'm in charge of Homeland
Security right like she could have left
but she's exercising her you know this
is she's taking responsibility for this
situation and that's a really incredibly
indelible and Powerful example of
exactly what you're talking about right
and and you and I have this privilege
that we get uh
scene
I love this song Everyday People by Sly
and the Family Stone there's a the real
reality I get to see is everyday Heroes
that there are Americans every day that
like Miss Jones who do things that that
are Beyond heroic
and they should be our our our anchors
um and when I was mayor I I would you
know there was this there was a guy that
would stop and see the graffiti on one
of our main arteries in Newark
Regular Joe but he started buying paint
and would just stop and paint a little
bit 10 minutes you're paying for 10
minutes and transform this place into an
ugly site to being someplace where
people didn't have to look at that filth
I I'd see a guy who used to stimulus
check back in the days that I think it
was Bush to buy a lawnmower and bags and
rakes and took an area that drug dealers
were using to sell in his neighborhood
never confronted them never vilified
them but would walk into their territory
gently and start mowing the lawn and
raking the leaves made it look like the
White House lawn and eventually the drug
dealers left on their own accord and he
became a hero in his community you know
I I could go through a thousand of these
stories you know police officers I had a
um
terrible situation where a woman
had had a hostage situation her
boyfriend jumps out of the
um window gets gets wounded but now
she's in there with a gun and a child
and my I'm talking to my Police director
about how to get her out and everybody's
safe the child safe and you hear these
gunshots go off and through the phone I
hear them and I hear again
police officers screaming go go go
they're running into a building with no
situational awareness
and they get up to the top of the stairs
and unfortunately the woman has
committed suicide
shot the baby through a pillow
and these these men and women try to
render Aid to the child
they just risk their own life
go to home whatever that home situation
is come back to work the next day to try
to help people
so I got this rare perch where I was
often being the pointer to the guys
mayor of the city but I presided over
City with thousands and thousands of
stories of people in the toughest of
circumstances that were willing to put
themselves on the line to to Love Thy
Neighbor
and and so whenever I get down or
whenever I'm facing fear or hurt or
frustrated because I can't get this bill
passed that seems to make a lot of sense
or or get my colleagues even in my own
party to sign on a bill that stop the
overuse of antibiotics in our system uh
um I I just simply need to reset to
people in tougher harsher circumstances
that somehow still seem to manifest the
highest of human virtue
and that's like a practice you'll bring
yourself back to that
um you know memory or root yourself in
in in that kind of experience to remind
yourself of why you're doing it yeah I
love that you use the word practice
because
um we all need to take one I would call
it a spiritual practice all of us have
to do things that can nurture and
nourish Us in order to be the best we
can at at admit and affecting this
frequency Mike Chief of Staff Veronica
extraordinary woman's on the plane with
me reading from a spiritual book about
how do you protect your frequency how do
you protect your energy because you've
got to have practices and I know I know
I am a much better
when I sleep when I get a full night's
sleep my my uncle says sleep is a weapon
and and whether you want to use that
language my language or not he's right I
when I'm sleeping I'm far more sharp and
far more effective I know that I need
exercise when I'm off the wagon and
Burying my sorrows in in vegan ice cream
I'm not at my best as I feel when I get
up in the morning and I meditate and I
pray and I journal and I read and I run
and get that surge of endorphins and
feel like I can take on the world I do
think and this is why I love listening
to you
um doing things that feed your soul and
surrounding yourself with people that
challenge you to be better and and to be
better at yourself and not to take
yourself too seriously and ground you
those are the kind of practices that we
all should be seeking and the pandemic
did something for me I
I realized that um since we were all
separate I had to be more active in
cultivating Community intentionally
creating community and I know that when
you surround yourself with the kind of
people that make you better you're
better off so I one of my close friends
uh Abe i s he and I agreed to start
studying Torah together I'm this
Christian guy but we said he's one of
the people I admire most in the world
and let's call in a rabbi and do some
virtue studying my cousins who I grew up
with that were like Brothers and Sisters
Let's create a well-being book Circle
and we created that the club has grown
this eight of us now that we meet weekly
and those are the kind of things that
are part of the practice of life and to
slow down enough to say what are the
ingredients I need to face a difficult
world because shock waves are going to
come
tragedies are going to come you're going
to wake up in the morning what are the
things that you need they're going to
keep you grounded help you build moral
muscle and spiritual resilience and we
should think about those things and if
we write those ingredients down how do
you incorporate them into your into your
into your into your daily routine yeah I
mean you're a caretaker for others
you're living a life of service uh but
your ability to serve to your maximum
capabilities is toggle to your ability
to exercise self-care right like you
can't if you're not taking care of
yourself you're not going to be able to
be the servant that you aspire to be
right and it's hard and I I I uh you
know I I listen to you and you're some
funny sayings like you wouldn't tell an
alcoholic to be moderate about you know
uh drinking uh just just do it
moderation and I'm learning my lines and
I'm learning when I fall off the wagon
and go through long periods where I'm
not doing something but this has been a
great few years to try new things like
yeah you know trying to run every day
you're on the run streak still right I
am on those so thanks to somebody shout
out to hella yeah who I met through who
I met through you you have influenced my
life more than you know trust me when
you like credited him tell and I were
texting did you see Corey yeah like and
it's and it's have you guys gone running
yet no we haven't you haven't but I ran
through covid I ran with uh I I was in
India and had this horrible thing happen
to my stomach that we should not
describe but I ran then I ran last night
was one of my toughest ones because
early morning you know three and a half
hours of sleep and at night going out
and running and my staff loves to pick a
hotel that's like on Hills
so it but it but it when I finished the
full year it talk about doing small
incremental things that build momentum
and then like I'm gonna do a hundred
push-ups a day which you know back in my
athletic days it would have been hard
but the first thing I was doing was like
three sets of three and and then by you
know I was did something that my chief
of staff again she's amazing but we joke
with each other all the time I did
something I was just down at the border
looking at the crisis there and I'm just
feeling so jacked that I challenge a
marine to a push-up contest because it's
you know these incremental things that
that really give you momentums creating
streaks uh creating habits it's so
empowering right again I I credit you
with a lot of this inspiration uh well
that's amazing to hear very cool
um I want to shift gears a little bit
you mentioned earlier
um
how you're sort of an unlikely candidate
for or to be this sort of advocate for
for food policy reform right this isn't
what you thought you would be getting
into but this has become really Central
to your platform and and and uh you know
your activism your advocacy uh and it's
interesting because on its face you
think well food food's like you know
this doesn't seem to be kind of in the
bullseye of like what Corey would be
concerned about but when you kind of
telescope out you realize like food is
everything it encapsulates all the
issues that you care about most so talk
a little bit about how you got
interested in in Food Systems and food
policy and kind of you know where we're
at right now in terms of what this looks
like yeah so I have a an amazing team
member named Adam Zipkin who's been with
me
for my whole pretty much my whole career
who was in Washington uh and basically
said we need to be on the agriculture
committee and I laughed at him
um and I don't know what that quote is
at first they laugh at you then they
fight you then they hate you or whatever
I think I went through all of them at
one point yeah yes yes
um and uh but eventually I end up on the
AG committee because we he argued and
rightfully so that every issue I care
about uh intersects with our food system
in fact everything intersects with our
food system and and I had been he and I
both sort of became uh vegetarians and
then vegans around the same Evolution
which gets you reading about food
um and I understood I went from a junk
food vegan to trying to be a more
plant-based person but it gives you
Windows into your food system so in
short
we are a country in in a Health crisis
that that we're not speaking about we
are the wealthiest country on in the
world but we have some of the highest
rates of diet related diseases that are
mushrooming in cost and just a handful
of years or like five are diabetes are
spending on uh diabetes
has gone up 25 half our population now
is diabetic or pre-diabetic but it's not
just diabetes it's uh Alzheimer's heart
disease stroke strokes and so one out of
every three dollars in our government
right now is being spent on health care
close to one out of five of our dollars
in our economy and I you know ran for
president where the debate people wanted
to have was how do you provide health
care but it's almost like saying it's
like well how do you mop up the floor
when the water is never turned so we
talk about why we need so much health
care yes if so 80 of that spending is
for diet related diseases and I'm all
for freedom I want I want this country
to eat what you want but we have
designed a system in which the things
that we tell you not to eat are being
subsidized and the things we tell you to
eat we don't subsidize at all so when my
kids walk into a bodega in Newark they
can get a twinkie-like product cheaper
than an apple because we as a society
have said we're going to subsidize
everything in that twinkie-like product
and not the Apple in fact fruits and
vegetables get about seven percent of
our AG subsidies while the commodity
crops that go to the the corn syrup and
the things that again are that are not
making us healthy or to feed animals get
the most of our subsidies and and
everybody on this along the chain is
getting hurt farmers are getting hurt
right now their suicide rates I think
are two or three times higher than the
average American the independent family
farmer is being eviscerated people are
losing their Farms other numbers again
it's massive corporate consolidation
small amounts of company are controlling
our food system and they're benefiting
from AG policies designed in the 1950s
by people who thought let's just make
calories readily available and that are
can stay on shelves forever when we know
a lot better about nutrition now
it this food system that we have is
being done in a way that is all about
those commodity crops which now are
being diced doused with chemicals that
we don't fully know what do does to our
bodies but you and I both have
glyphosates in our blood other endocrine
disruptors because we've created this
you know Roundup Ready crops and seeds
which are hurting our ecology streams
Rivers full of these chemicals runoff of
we're losing quality of our soil so
farmers are losing the ecology is losing
climate change it's one of our biggest
contributors to the problem all these
climate activists seem to always forget
that our food system is one of the major
contributors to that farmers could be
leading us out of that with us
incentivizing them to do farming
practices cover crops and other things
that preserve uh um soil nutrient-rich
soil biodiverse soil as opposed to the
dirt that's created when you calcium
glyphosate so it's a climate change
issue it's ecology issue it's about our
Farmers but it's also about our food
workers
people who work in our food system first
of all overwhelmingly undocumented
immigrants
our our Farms they're picking most of
the food we eat even to our
slaughterhouses which are more corporate
concentrated than during the time of uh
Upton Sinclair's the jungle so you go
all the way to the end users as a guy
that you know Ron Finley says uh in
South Central he's in South Central
we've got drive-bys and drive-throughs
and the drive-throughs are killing more
people than than the drive-bys the
number one killer of African Americans
is Diet related diseases so this food
system is so broken it's hurting us in
every single way from the farmers who
are producing our food who now get 14
cents on the dollar of every consumer
dollar spent
um because of again massive corporate
concentration all the way down to very
very sick population and so I think we
as a society no matter your right or
left I told you about the Cattlemen who
were getting hurt by this system all the
way to the people in communities like
mine we need to begin to expand
Consciousness about that this is not a
fate of complete that this system is by
Design producing the results that we're
seeing where pharmaceutical companies
are making incredible profits where
literally I was shocked when I saw this
that a major Health Organization says
well obesity and children such a bad
thing we we are advising them to have
their stomach stapled
um um so we have created a system where
people are profiting off of it but the
rest of us all are losing and we could
just redesign it so farmers Thrive and
consumers thrive in health uh because we
know as you've said it many times
unusual food is medicine I can show you
study after study that for taxpayers if
you're a fiscally conservative what a
return on on investment if you make
fresh fruits and vegetables accessible
for people with diabetes or hypertension
or the like and so I want to be a
disrupter now I want to find ways to
take the next farm bill which is coming
and see what ways we can make
improvements on it to begin to show
people there's a better way there's so
much uh
change that we need right now and it is
true like when you kind of canvas the
current situation everybody's losing
except the people in the c-suites of
these Giant Food conglomerates and
perhaps the lobbyists who are on
retainer right like
this is a [__] you know Bar None
in terms of trying to you know kind of
create any kind of meaningful change
it's an intractable problem and it's
super entrenched right but what's
interesting about it is it really is a
bipartisan issue like the people that
are suffering are blue and they're red
and we should all be very concerned
about this and we can all benefit and
gain from looking more closely at what
is actually going on where the money is
Flowing who is being harmed and you know
not for nothing the long-term
consequences of not addressing this
problem which will ultimately bankrupt
the country because if you think
healthcare is expensive and inaccessible
now what is it going to look like if you
know these curves towards uh you know
greater and greater diabetes rates and
and obesity and heart disease and the
like they're only going to continue to
escalate well if you look at the call
then it becomes it becomes a national
security issue like there is nothing
that is not impacted by this it all goes
back to food and what's interesting when
you look at the history of it going all
the way back to like the Homestead Act
and the original you know rationale
behind the farm bill right like good
intentions let's let's have cheap food
for everybody that lasts on the Shelf
like these are good things we need this
to combat
um you know our hunger issue right but
here we are today it's a very different
situation and we have a farm bill
situation that's perpetuating a problem
the problems rather than eradicating
them and I know that you've admit you've
you've put a couple pieces of
legislation on the table right now to
redress this it's a very exciting time
because the farm bill is up for vote I
think in September this year right so we
hope we hope yeah yeah we don't it's not
like how does that I don't even know how
that works and the the legislation that
you've you've kind of authored or
co-authored is that part of the farm
bill or how I don't know that I fully
understand yeah so you always work big
things called reauthorizations you know
the FAA reauthorization but the farm
bills every five years it's the whole
thing things up again but it's kind of
like five to seven years like it's vague
it could yeah it could take longer to
get done yeah but there is usually these
must pass bills it's going to eventually
pass but there's a whole bunch of
fighting involved in it and and and a
lot of bipartisan work and so we try to
we're trying to find things that we can
tweak in different places that might
have big results like there's something
and again I hate to speak Washington
speak called the Gus snip program what
is that that is like to incentivize
people one part of the farm bill is what
used to call food stamps but snap
supplement right A nutrition assistance
program where what can you do with your
snap dollars well there's a program that
was created that would allow people to
go to farmers markets and and and uh and
urban Farms because you used to not be
able to to use them for anything healthy
yes right yes we can buy as much sugar
water as you want but uh there are other
things that you couldn't do well once we
realized we can create incentives you
can get uh gusts simple houses you get
double bucks and so in Newark when I was
mayor we were able to create an entire
city block as a farm and I went back
recently I hadn't been there in years I
was blown away by what they've created
in this space and I went to see what I
could buy with you know ten dollars and
it blew anything away that I could get
in like Whole Foods or the organic
section of other places and then they
told me well you would get double this
with your food stamps I tried to live
um did a horrible job but I wanted to
show how hard it was to live and feed
yourself on the 2.14 cents a day that
they or I'm not sure exactly what it is
now but
um the little bit of money you get per
meal or for the day but this was
unbelievable to me and and I met a group
out there you know the documentary food
Inc sure well they're filming food ink
too and so I went to talk about this
challenge that we have of this these
mushrooming costs where we will you say
someday it's soon where the amount of
money we spend on health care because
these diseases are mushrooming the one
that people don't talk but enough is
Alzheimer's which you and people you've
had on have talked about being type 3
diabetes because it's so connected to
our diet as well
I went out to talk to them about that
and I and we didn't plan it this way but
these African-American Elder women come
out and want to share their stories one
woman had a gut issues where she said
that her prescription drugs were costing
700 a month
she was paying a hundred dollars of it
that was her copay
and so I assume taxpayers were paying
the rest of it and she said that she
started sourcing all of her food from
this incredible Farm in a low-income
section of the city and and her doctor's
like miracle cure you don't need your
prescription drugs she became healthy an
octogenarian she's in great Twitter hand
uh Instagram handle like vegan
octogenarian or something like that 80
year old woman
who had diabetes for years and years and
years became a vegan source for food
from the form it went away her diabetes
went away
and so that's the the crossroads I think
we're on we do not understand how bad
it's going to get in 10 20 years if we
don't do something about this crisis but
there's ways in the farm bill that if we
start to make changes I think we can
create even more
constructive disruption but to your
point they're very powerful lobbies that
are trying to protect the status quo who
don't want to see change in these areas
and they often have influence on both
sides of the aisle like uh you know my
team we stopped taking corporate
contributions and uh c-suite from oil
companies or Pharma but I try to often
tell people the the most influential
Lobby is uh food right food because they
are on both sides of the aisle it's uh I
mean it's probably not as big as defense
though right or is it is it is it is it
on parody with that I would I would
actually you just uh uh Trump me a
little bit because defense is um defense
hard to beat defense it is really hard
to start the board against defense bills
because sorry go ahead well I just was
joking because it's happened again
Democrat Republican presidents they
often put their budgets in for defense
and Congress takes it okay the military
is asking for this let's add you know
whatever billions of dollars on to it
because you know the military is not
asking for things that are made in my
district or what have you uh I still
remember my funny experiences was going
to John McCain's Ranch it was another
guy being very close to on the Odyssey
of meeting with everybody when I went to
his office we had a very emotional first
meeting and he kind of took me under his
wing and was so kind to me so he started
inviting me to these annual policy
conferences at his Ranch and I was out
there and I I um couldn't eat anything
at his big barbecue one night because
everything was saturated and some Animal
product you know the vegetables for
butter and mayonnaise and so I just
didn't eat but I was comfortable really
happy to be in this policy conference
and as I'm driving away in a golf cart
the guy's taking me back to where I was
staying on his Ranch he said you enjoy
the food center I'm like I actually
really didn't have any food because
nothing was vegan he said oh my God can
we help you get food and I go yeah sure
and he goes well I think Senator
McCain's probably asleep but maybe we
can break into his back door and go into
his kitchen I'm like break into John
McCain's house yeah I'm in I'm from
Jersey baby let's go and so
um we go there we didn't have to break
in but because he was sitting up late
talking to a former Secretary of the
Navy and I sit there with my peanut
butter and carrots or whatever I was
eating just listen to these two wise men
talk about what they were calling the
corruption in our military that we have
we're spending so much more and not
getting the effectiveness we should uh
because we're just a failure to focus on
taxpayer uh uh return for investment and
so I just think this is where I think my
party gets it wrong or doesn't say it
enough we really have got to start
talking about uh reforming systems
creating more transparency less
um
uh uh sort of these opaque worlds in
which all this corruption can Thrive and
I think that we need to a a reimagining
of what government is because we have a
government right now that in so many
cases would rather pay so much more on
the back end of a problem as opposed to
make more strategic Investments on the
front end and this brings us back to
food when I talk to people at the state
department when I talk to people in the
military and look at their threat
analyzes they are going to tell you that
one of the great crises we have is food
insecurity
that often causes political instability
that often causes migration crises a lot
of the challenges we have at the border
you could say are coming from political
instability
over the years some of these countries
some of which America has had a role in
but there's also just you know the the
the the the
craziness of the weather destroying
agricultural crops creating poverty
there's something going on the planet
that we aren't we can't isolate
ourselves from as a country and I love
what General Mattis says if you stop the
state department funding for certain
programs then buy me more bullets
um the way you stop crying in
communities like mine in Newark or pick
your city I still remember heading with
the head of the FBI and saying how do we
solve this problem and when I was first
weeks I was married he goes we don't
solve this problem there he said to me
we treat the symptoms of a problem
whether it's in the United States
starting to own up to issues of
addiction and mental health which we
fill our prisons with these folks so
much more expensive
so much more human misery as opposed to
finding interventions on the front end
planetarily if we don't start finding
ways to intervene in countries that are
at risk in programs we know have
returned for taxpayer dollars that help
with food Innovations access to uh uh uh
to food security and more we are going
to pay so much more in the back end of
these problems and so that's enlightened
empathy that understands that this isn't
charity it's the self-interest we have
to play a role of creating a more
healthy uh planet and in America
stop creating an environment where we
deal with our crises in hospital
emergency rooms or in prisons or in
jails but starts to say how can we
create a more Beloved Community where
we're making Investments that are not
just in human well-being to help human
flourishing but actually make us a safer
Society a more Beloved Country and a
nation that is more evidencing its best
values and how we treat one another
through our policies and through our
individual behaviors when it comes to
Food Systems however that solution rests
in
dismantling a corporate conglomerate
system of factory farms and cafos that
are depleting our soils and you know
reaping the benefits of subsidies and
producing foods that are making us ill
uh you know on the on the sort of
shoulders of of taxpayers yes who
actually incur the risk when things go
sideways like
combating that or or you know kind of
innovating new systems is a is a tough
mountain to climb right so you as
somebody who sits on the Senate uh you
know agriculture committee like are you
an outlier voice on that committee is
there consensus building happening right
now are there Solutions on the table
about how to effectively
you know achieve this to repair our
soils and to
um you know get people to appreciate the
benefits of more kind of locally
oriented agricultural sources I know you
talk about like the robustness of you
know dispersing
uh you know our food systems because
covid if it taught us anything it taught
us how fragile it is global the
concentration of our yeah the
globalization of our food system
actually makes us very very
um sensitive and fragile in times of
Crisis yeah look
we have produced legislation going right
at this factory farm system that is
indefensible they do a lot these AG gag
laws to stop Americans from knowing yeah
you were talking about transparency we
don't know anything we're legally
prevented from from actually being able
to understand and they literally cover
it over if you go to these massive
concentrated animal feeding operations
these kfos they're literally covering
them over they are these sort of they're
acting in ways that are affronts to the
values of their consumers putting
beautiful pictures on their packaging of
you know these pastoral days of past or
days that reflect more what the
regenerative movement's doing than what
is actually happening with most of the
meat that we're producing
um they're doing things to animals that
would discussed uh uh many of their
consumers
um so I could go on about the factory
farming we have put forward legislation
but this is something you have you know
about Washington
ultimately change does not come from
Washington it comes to Washington like
we didn't get uh the the great suffrage
uh uh uh you know legislation because in
1919 a bunch of men came to the senate
floor and said okay fellas I guess what
let's let those women have a right to
vote it came because of activism of
conscious expansion we didn't get civil
rights legislation because one day Strom
Thurman came to the senate floor and
said I've seen the light let those negro
people have the right to vote we came
because of activism that was so the as I
said before these artists of activism
that opened the eyes of the average
Americans who could not no longer
sanction uh the this segregation we are
in that same moment uh right now where
we share the same values about our food
system we could have a focus group here
of any background of Americans
moms want healthy foods for their kids
they often are confused by the
corporations that try to confuse them
with their labeling and their marketing
moms want healthy food you give them the
options they're going to choose healthy
foods for their families but but we need
to continue to let people understand
what's happening in their food system
when I can talk to other colleagues of
mine in Congress
and say things that that that sort of
blow their mind that they didn't realize
are happening or just tell stories what
did it what it did for me to go to
Duplin County North Carolina
and see what Smithfield one of the
companies is doing down there with these
contract farmers who themselves are
trapped in these horrible tournament
systems where they're living like
sharecroppers but I had never seen with
my own eyes these massive cafos that
then underneath have grapes where these
caged animals who can barely move or
turn around then have their feces and
urine flow through these pipes into
these massive lagoons of waste that are
then sprayed on fields but just like
when you spray your fire hose stuff
Mists and then you meet with people
desperate Americans who've lived on that
land for Generations in this case black
communities have been on that land since
slavery
say to you their property values have
crashed they have respiratory problems
diseases they can't open their Windows
they can't uh uh run their air
conditioning or put their clothing on
the lines and the hell that they're
going through as a result of this
aberration of the way we're raising
livestock you can't help but break open
your empathy and feel compelled that we
have to change the system it doesn't
have to be this way I can still enjoy uh
uh whatever I want to eat
from systems that are healthy that that
add to our well-being that don't oppress
or exploit people that don't drive uh uh
uh people who have a proud Heritage in
their family of raising livestock now to
their knees living like sharecroppers
but the problem we have right now is not
enough Americans realize how deeply
broken this system is and how we're all
losing and so what I'm trying to do and
what people like you are doing because
I've learned a lot from years ago
starting to listen to what you all are
doing is this is the 1950s in the Civil
Rights Movement I had the and I hope I'm
not getting control for outing him the
head of the NAACP saying you had
mentioned to me Corey one of these food
Summits civil rights food Summit because
a lot of the Civil Rights organizations
when they would come to me and they
would say this is our agenda for black
American I'd be like where is the food
the number one killer of African
Americans is because you have more fast
food restaurants in African-American
communities people are not having it
their own way though you know there's no
happiness in a lot of these happy meals
that they're having why aren't we having
conversations we're removing activist
groups and I don't care who you I I gave
a speech to this amazing Coalition of
farmers of Health Advocates livestock
Farmers getting together with animal
rights people we need to strengthen
these coalitions build this
Consciousness so that Americans are
saying no more why are you putting my
life in danger by overusing antibiotics
why are you doing things that don't
comport you and I remember the dolphin a
cause that got Americans all up and they
tried to change the way they were doing
this fish why aren't we demanding that
our this factory farming stop in this
country and US begin to do things that
localize and regionalize our food
systems make them stronger healthier and
more elevating to the the success of
families and farmers and everybody in
between yeah yeah the the
disproportionate impact that this system
is having on you know commute
underprivileged communities communities
of color I mean it it it's deplorable
and but nobody and yet but I'm sorry
because
so the the United Farm Workers invited
100 Senators to come work a day in the
fields
next to a farm worker two two of us
responded Alex Padilla here in
California said I I will do it and me it
took us like over a year to schedule
this and I go out in this in this in
these fields
it was brutally hard work
hunched over picking lettuce doing all
these things I think my chief of staff
who's here took the team took Joy
filming me I'm a pretty I'm pretty good
shape but it was brutal work
I was sore for well over a week
but what's interesting to me is I talked
to these mostly women
and
my expansion is pretty good and and all
of them aren't most of them are
undocumented
and they have horrible stories of sexual
harassment wage theft
what does it mean to have to work away
from your children in ways that are
wrong
the challenges of sending money working
like we did and then sending money back
just the usury rates that are charged
all these issues as we're as we're going
through this process of me trying not to
faint out there
um and I'll never forget getting back to
this farmer was really reputable he was
telling me stories about about what
other folks were doing to a lot of these
workers and the levels of exploitation
and most Americans don't know most of
the food we consume
is being uh picked or harvested or what
have you by people that live in the
shadows but he says something to me that
like shook me because he's like this is
the owner of the farm he says to me he
goes well yeah Corey America has
throughout its history had the people
that work in their fields not having any
say in their political systems you would
understand that as a black guy and all
of a sudden it like gave me chills I'm
like oh my God this guy's going all the
way back to slavery
and and so I know the average American
if they went through what I did side by
side with these other human beings
listening to their stories of of sexual
exploitation economic exploitation to
know that this Injustice is baked into
our food system would say enough is
enough we need to change this and we can
do it in a way that's not going to
actually raise costs for families that's
the thing that most people don't
understand that there's a lot of
corporate taking going on where they're
exploiting a system and draining more
and more out of the system and the
people getting hurt are not just the
agricultural workers go to a rural Town
one of my partners on some of this
legislation is an unlikely guy but he's
the only Farmer in the United States
Senate this incredible Senator named
John tester uh in Montana which is a red
state but he's a moderate guy who
survives seems every re-election effort
and he has a joke and I got to get the
exact right but it goes something like
this he goes my when I was growing up in
Montana in my town in Montana
our high school had like 2 000 kids we
had like three banks in our downtown and
five bars and he goes now we've got like
200 kids in our town because all the
corporate consolidation like 200 kids in
our high school there are no more Banks
and there's only one bar that's hanging
on because I go there and drink all the
time and and what he just tells is the
hollowing out of our of our of our rural
communities because again multinational
corporations are what used to sustain
thriving diverse communities farming
like our great-grandparents did are now
being run by these massive multinational
corporations that are doing everything
they can to protect this broken uh a
farm system so so we can change this but
the first step goes back to what we were
talking about in the beginning
individuals like you and I and people
that are listening saying
uh before I'm going to just point
fingers at the kfos and these companies
what can I be doing to better send
ripples out of of empathy and
understanding to all aspects of this
system what can I do to raise
Consciousness and join it because I feel
like we're in the 1950s of the
ultimately Victorious uh uh Civil Rights
Movement where where what they were
doing was Raising Consciousness all
along the way of the injustices well we
have to do this because to me the
injustices Run Deep in in in in in in
the exploitation and the hurting of
farmers and the hurting of our
atmosphere this is a big big problem
that I I'm hoping more people can take
the time to learn about uh uh and and
connect themselves to well I appreciate
you shouldering the responsibility of of
attempting to educate people it is so
complex and there is no aspect as we
said earlier of of society that is
Untouched by this right and it isn't a
blue or a red thing the farmers are
hurting saying they're being exploited
the workers are being exploited the
consumers are are are are being
exploited our health is being impacted
the environment is being degraded the
animals are being horribly they're you
know it's just it's just
terrible across the board and
I do believe in in change and I do think
that you know that education Piece Will
and is already creating a Grassroots
movement of of excitement and energy
around this type of change and then
there's you you know sitting where you
sit who gets to talk who gets to
initiate legislation who gets to talk
about the Anti-Trust implications of all
of this who gets to you know kind of uh
you know convene hearings where you get
to confront these corporations and ask
them the hard questions all of which
trickles down into more education and
more energy
so we we uh you know we stopped taking
corporate dollars and corporate packs
and all that so we do a lot of these
emails that you might get from people
trying to raise money so we just think
it's almost uh affirming to us that
we'll send out emails with you know I
think incredibly Barbra Streisand sent
out an email with us that was very
successful we'll you know try to you
know talk about every issue to see if we
can get individual small dollar
contributions because ultimately yeah
and the ones that get the best return
are about the food system there's an
audience out there the best performing
posts we often have are talking about
the food system so I know some of it
might be because these are the people
that are drawn but I I do think there's
more and more pun intended appetite out
there for information and to support
people like yourself and others who are
really trying to tell speak truth to
power and do something about about this
ultimately at the highest level though
the incentive the incentives have to
change right we have to create healthier
incentives we have to create incentives
that drive the positive change and right
now all of the incentives are driving
you know us in the wrong direction and
just making this problem even more
intractable and you know when it comes
to like
campaign Finance reform and you know the
whole like K Street complex like help us
understand like how that works like you
know what is the shadowy business of
being a lobbyist like is it somebody
lurking in the hallways of you know the
these Senate and Congressional Office
Buildings waiting to you know have a
meeting and entice you know a
representative with vacations and you
know condos like yeah what is it what is
the reality of that
so I I don't want to vilify any there's
lobbyists who come up and Lobby for
cancer research lobbyists so there's you
know you you always don't want to cast a
broad net
um and then there's the old joke you
know don't hate the player hate the game
the game is designed in certain rules
yeah people are playing their parts and
if we can change the rules of the game
you're going to get a lot different
results so yes we live in a nation right
now especially since citizens united
that to run for a congressional seat or
a senate seat takes an ungodly amount of
money
uh we're the only nation I know that
does it this way where we're in 2023 we
have a November 2024 presidential
election and people are already out
there raising money for what's going to
be an interminably long campaign you
know it's our you know in the in a
parliamentary system in England they're
like set an election three months later
it's over
um and and so corporations right now
have a corrupting info if you read
citizens united which is one of the more
shocking decisions which opened up the
floodgates all of this dark money even
they said well we should disclose it we
should have forget it it's a corrupting
system that we have right now that if
you have two candidates that each raise
25 million dollars that's still often a
fraction of the total money spent
because now corporations without their
fingerprints on it can dump millions of
dollars I watched one Congress person I
know was was doing good at like a week
before his election and a corporation
just came in and dumped all these
horrible negative ads accusations
against them and they narrowly lost
their election and so there are certain
things I that I think we should be
all fighting for that are technical
fixes to our democracy that would
produce better results whether you're
democrat or republican you would want
that change and one of them is has to be
like we were the fourth Senator to take
the citizen United pledge to give up
corporate Pac money and the whole thing
and I'm trying to show people you can
live without it depend upon small dollar
contributions but hey before you
contribute to somebody ask them have
they taken the pledge too we've got to
somehow disconnect our elected leaders
from this this corporate uh these this
this corporate money and get them to
pass laws that end the citizens united
there's other things that we got to
change too though I mean you know
how we draw district lines and
gerrymandering and again this is not a
partisan thing you see gerrymandering on
both sides of the aisle but it
disenfranchises people increase the
Democracy where as I said you know
voters don't get to pick their elected
officials elected officials they have to
pick their voters
so there there's systems designs just
like our food system is designed to get
the outcome we're seeing our political
system there's things we could do better
like I've become enamored recently with
uh uh with ranked Choice voting
um uh and I'm starting to look at it in
working that when you go in you don't
just vote for your Top Choice you vote
for your second choice and your third
choice which could have I know in my
side of the aisle like when Hillary
Clinton was running if you just took the
Jill Stein people that voted that could
have ranked Hillary as a second choice
it's something that could have pulled
her over over the top so I just hope
people again
everything we are enjoying in this
incredible privilege to be the rare four
percent of the population of the Earth
could they call themselves American it
could come with obligations and
responsibilities one of which is how do
you leave this nation better than when
you inherited it how do you leave our
democracy stronger than when you
inherited it and we now have a democracy
that's straining a little bit I don't
think there's anything that's happening
now that's unprecedented if you read
history
it's a very precedented time there's
been other times that our democracy has
felt like it was on their brain to
people or where extremism was Rising but
the question always comes back to you as
an actor what are you willing to do
about the about the challenges it's
something we should do and I get
frustrated sometimes when people tell me
oh politics I'm not I'm not oh it's just
too I don't want to get involved I'm
sorry well if you abdicate your
responsibility from being engaged in the
Civic space uh um
you are contributing to the problems you
say you don't like and making things
worse because ultimately you get the
electorate you get the elected leaders
that you deserve and one of the reasons
why bad people I hate to put that in
that way I put it in quotes but bad
people are elected this because good
people don't vote don't participate
foreign
yeah the silence is is just as potent as
what you say yeah yeah and I again
good people who do nothing those are the
folks that are the letters from the
Birmingham Jail which I think people
should reread once a year was King not
writing to racists or segregationists he
was writing to people of faith that were
criticizing him for his activism and and
and wanted to really believe that those
were the people that the real were the
real threat not the people that were
that were simply perpetrating the the
segregation it was why are so many
people sitting on the sideline
um and luxuriating in the benefits on
the blessings of of of their good
fortune and not understanding that they
were uh their complicity uh was was what
was sourcing the sustainability of the
problem
um
well Senator I want to be uh considerate
of your time uh we should probably wrap
this up but but before I let you go you
know on that note of of kind of our
civic responsibility and you know
assuming that like myself people who are
listening to this or watching it are are
feeling inspired and energized around
the idea of perhaps getting a little bit
more activated or involved in in issues
that they care about than they have
historically and even maybe specifically
to the Food Systems issue like how do
you how do you kind of encourage people
to get more involved like are there
certain things that you could you know
advise or recommend people to look into
or how to use their voice specifically
well I'd love to work with you put some
things in the show notes yeah might give
people uh links and ways to get involved
every dollar you spend in your life is a
vote
um and I'm trying to think more about
everything from where my clothing comes
from to where my food comes from and if
you have the flexibility to make choices
you can endorse a lot of good practices
that are starting
um you had a
a guy again you've you've turned me on
to a lot of people over the years one of
them this guy I love uh Zach Bush
um I'm seeing him later this week you
you hang out with people I want to hang
out with are you around on Friday I wish
now I wish I was uh that guy is
incredible he's been in my office and
and sat with a bunch of senators I got
him a handful of Senators but I love
what he says like we often think that we
have to attack the darkness and don't
realize that we could just be more light
ourselves and and so I just hope people
just do a rigorous interrogation of
themselves every once they don't do it
every day but what are the practices I
can change because
um that's where that's where you can
make a difference so we'll give
practical things I'll I'll give you the
names of legislation that we're working
on that you could ask your
representative what have you but my
biggest thing and you and I even when we
were in college they would have groups
get together to talk about some issue
and everybody would leave feeling better
about themselves but not say it's again
it's not about what others are doing
it's what about what I'm doing and I'll
end if I can with uh now that I've told
you too many stories but to tell you you
know one of my favorite moments of Shame
which I can uh which you will hopefully
give me Absolution for but
um I have this great uh man in my life
named Kevin Batts who's a was him on my
security detailed police officer when I
was
uh security detail when I left City Hall
he's like I want to stay with you on
your team so I literally hired him on my
sentence team and he's one of these guys
that helps with a lot of security issues
and support when I'm back home so he's
been driving me around for a long time
and we've been in this car since 2006
and so he we don't have to speak and
when I'm back working and trying to
return calls he can just look in the
rear view mirror and understand what I'm
thinking he's got this like incredible
psychic ability so we're driving along
and this is where I need some
forgiveness because I did not know at
this point in my life that McDonald's
french fries are not vegan that they
they doused them in meat juice or
something like that I mean you know it's
it's an easy mistake okay yes yeah so
we're driving past the McDonald's just
three blocks from my house and he looks
at me in the rearview mirror and he sees
the shame in my eyes and he turns into
the drive-through mirror without
anything being she turns into the
drive-through without anything being
said and uh you know the flesh is weak I
need these french fries and I go into
the thing and I order these two large
french fries now I am I'm one of the
biggest I'm not we're probably the lead
in descheduling psychedelics you've had
some great shows about the power of
descheduling marijuana
um
um and yet somehow I think that
McDonald's french fries should be
scheduled because they sprinkle them
with something I'm just so happy I get
these things I'm holding them like I'm
you know my precious and I want to give
them back to my powerless yes and and
but as we start to drive I see a guy in
a trash can rooting around and I look in
the mirror eyes meet no word said he
stops he knows me and I really know my
windows hey man what's up and I realized
my tone of my voice wasn't
um respecting his dignity and and then I
sort of shipped it came in a different
way I said sir is there anything I can
do to help you and he turns around and
goes I'm hungry and as I always say you
know you got to follow your faith and uh
you know my religion says something
about if you have two McDonald's french
fries and your neighbor has none you got
to give them
one of your fries I call it the sermon
on the mcmount I hand him this
McDonald's french fries out the window
we seem like we're gonna have a
beautiful exchange she seems happy to
receive them I feel good about myself
and I now want to get home because
there's nothing worse than cold
McDonald's french fries but then he asks
me he goes do you have any socks
and I know people who experience
homelessness this is it could be a big
thing but I don't carry extra socks in
my car and I sort of look to my left and
right vainly and I say sorry I'm sorry I
don't he said okay he stepped away
holding one of the fries and
um I roll up the window and I turned for
uh Kevin to drive and he doesn't drive
he doesn't read the signs
um he puts the car in park reaches
between his legs on the steering wheel
kicks off his shoes takes off the socks
he's wearing and hands them out the door
the guy looked like he received the bar
gold and I'm sitting back there thinking
to myself I'm the senator that runs
around talking about kindness and
decency and love and living your values
but in this moment I didn't think to
take off my damn socks I went on three
blocks from my house I have socks in my
drawer I probably haven't worn yet
and so what I try to remind myself is
that this is that word you said earlier
it is a practice that trying every day
to get up to live your values is
something that's not hard but you it it
is it demands of us that whether we
stumble we fall we just get up every day
and try our best to live our light and a
life of that it's not a straight line it
takes stumbles you get hit you get
knocked down but getting up every day
and trying to practice
kindness decency and love I think that
that's the highest calling of life
whether you are an elected leader
whether you are a a a coach whatever you
have that to me other people people who
live that kind of Life those are the
people that help light my path like
Kevin bats that encourage me in my way
um
well I think he stuck the landing with
that one beautifully but I appreciate
um I appreciate that that's a a really
powerful reminder and uh you know before
we sign off just I want to just
acknowledge you for for your example and
and you know the the light that you
admit and the example that you set for
so many people
you you let me just finish no I can't
take it from you I think the things you
say the good or bad what you say about
other people is a moral reflection of
who you are than of who you're talking
about you are
um truly truly one of the great uh
Inspirations uh uh to have you as a
source in my life is incredible you've
been at this for years now I I feel like
I know you uh because I listened to you
for so long so I appreciate that you're
keeping me on kindness but today please
let me just say on behalf of your
listeners on the path people don't get
the privilege that I get have now gotten
to meet you you are our amazing humble
kind and the wisdom you bring out from
others and that you share on a regular
basis is making this world a better
place and it's definitely made me a
better man yeah I appreciate that thank
you thank you and uh you're you're
always welcome back here I I want to
come out and hang out with you whether
this cream
let's do dinner let's do dinners and
open up the mic all right thanks man
thank you thank you peace
[Music]
thanks